tous ici on pense en images ne traite
pas bien langue c'est pas l'arabe c'est
pas le français s'est pas l'anglais
c'est l'image
un dessinateur de presse et avant tout
un nouveau batteur
sinon on n'est pas des politiciens on
n'est pas payé pour régler les conflits
ailleurs le cndd soutiendra aussi
rapidement atteint l'année nous pourrons
kg où tu affrontes il dessinait sarkozy
et je rajoutais deux pieds comme ça et
le dessin était fini
c'est un vaisseau at il argué you and i
know you lie on est pour quelques
marines alliées à la calle pour que ne
pourriez pas ça râle
sony france par les eaux
je pensais pas que j'allais utiliser mon
coup de peinture rouge autrement que
pour faire le drapeau tunisien
tu peux publier ça dans les bus ça va ça
n'existe pas un dessin qui puisera
personnes ça n'existe pas collet qui est
rien très costaud et bientôt car la
caricature la république à la loupe et
semir indra
manipulation berra au cas
alors qu'apple allure tap
est ce un élément fondamental à la vie
10 43